so when you're working out there's some
very important things that you want to
do before during and after your exercise
and this especially applies as we age
because as we age there's so many
different illnesses that are connected
with aging exercise seems to be one of
the best things to counter that in fact
I mentioned this in another video the
lack of exercise or activity actually
causes some of these illnesses and one
of the real big things that exercise can
do is increase your mitochondria now
mitochondria is the energy Factory of
the cell it's the thing that converts
food into energy as well as the raw
materials to build body tissue and
exercise directly increases the number
of mitochondria and that's important
because so many diseases are related to
mitochondrial dysfunction including
cancer so anything you could do to
improve the mitochondria the better it's
going to be for your health now I just
want to mention some thing called stem
cells when you exercise you increase
your stem cells they're cells that are
not really anything yet they're kind of
potential body tissue so they can turn
into anything that you need like joint
tissue or pancreas tissue or your liver
or anything and when we get older our
stem cells go down but exercise can help
rejuvenate a lot of your stem cells so
if you're not exercising you need to
start and being consistent especially as
you age also exercise is one of the best
things to reduce stress because we all
experience stress we want to keep the
stress very low if you don't exercise
you're going to find that your stress
levels go up exercise will also help
sleep blood sugars there's just many
many benefits so the first point about
exercise I want to bring up is the four
variables to exercise really exercise
consists of four things one is the
duration of exercise how long you go two
is the intensity of your exercise
three is the recovery after the exercise
and four is just the frequency of how
many times you do that for a given
workout or how many workouts you do for
a given week so all the different types
of exercises that are out there are
really just a combination of these four
things the first thing I'm going to talk
about is the recovery okay the rest not
necessarily Just Between the workouts
like how many times you go per week but
how long do you rest between your actual
sets so let's say for example you do
like eight reps of a certain exercise
which kind of makes up what's called a
set now how long do you uh rest between
these sets a lot of people when they do
the high intensity interval training
um spend like 30 seconds resting let me
tell you the problem with that one is
that you don't give your body a chance
to replenish the ATP so if you only rest
for 30 seconds and then you go right
into the next exercise without that full
ATP or energy to supply the muscle
you're not going to be able to train at
that maximum output that you would if
you rested a little bit longer and this
could inhibit your progress especially
if you're training for something like
sprinting or some type of high intensity
sport 30 second rest is not going to be
enough you're not going to replenish
your ATP the best thing to do especially
if you're doing this high intensity
interval training to rest like four to
five minutes between these sets that'll
give your body a chance to replenish the
ATP and be able to train for more
maximum power because also the intensity
is really the key with exercise the more
intense the more growth hormone the more
muscle Activation so it's much smarter
to focus on the intensity City and less
reps and maybe more sets then bring your
intensity down because you're too tired
and then try to do like a lot of reps
because now you have to lower the weight
and then you do less sets so more rest
between the sets lower reps high
intensity also a lot of the benefit from
this exercise especially high intensity
occurs one to two days later when you're
sleeping you're creating all this damage
with the muscle and then in the repair
process your body becomes stronger
because it's adapting to that stress and
let me just touch a little bit more on
this high intensity interval training so
let's say for example
you do some type of exercise to get your
pulse rate really really high right so
let's say it's sprinting your sprinting
as fast as you can for 10 seconds and
your pulse rate comes all the way up to
I don't know maybe 160 170 or higher
what's causing that to go higher is the
sympathetic nervous system at the point
where you're done sprinting
whether it's sprinting or maybe even
running up the stairs you're now going
to rest and a lot of people do what's
called active recovery which they they
maybe walk in place or they're doing
some type of exercise where they're
still exercising but not as a higher
intensity and that might work for some
people if you're maybe doing sprinting
and walking but a much better idea would
be to come to a full stop after the
Sprint so why would a full stop be
better than this active recovery well
because when you stop working out after
a high intense type of activity your
pulse rate is going to come down right
what's causing the pulse rate to come
down is something called the
parasympathetic nervous system
it kind of opposes this sympathetic
response so the sympathetic is raising
your pulse rate that parasympathetic is
actively pushing that pulse rate down
much similar to when you pump the brakes
after you're going fast in your car you
pump the brakes you let off the gas
now we're pumping the brakes the
parasympathetic come in there and
actually push your pulse rate down so
when you come to a full stop and you're
not exercising
and you're sitting there
your body is exercising the
parasympathetic nervous system and this
is a kind of a subtle thing but an
important thing to do if you want to
exercise and make stronger your recovery
and the reason I know about this is in
practice I had something called heart
rate variability uh testing unit and I
would measure the recovery after
exercise and those people who did this
where they basically came to a Full Stop
started to show stronger parasympathetic
nervous system control over time and
also remember that the vagus nerve is
part of that parasympathetic nervous
system that's the main nerve that
controls a lot of the the digestive
system the heart and many of the organs
in your abdomen area and a strong
parasympathetic nervous system will help
you sleep at night help you recover
especially after exercise the next thing
I want to bring up is something called
contrast therapy where after an exercise
you either take a cold shower okay and
then you maybe take a hot shower or you
can do an ice bath and a sauna or a
Whirlpool now there's a lot of data to
show that that really helps recovery and
repair and it speeds up the Rejuvenation
process of that muscle damage decreasing
the inflammation and just decreasing the
time it takes to repair now I've been
experimenting with this and I found that
I'm getting a lot of recovery after I do
this cold water immersion I have this
unit that I jump into I use this app to
the workout it seems to be working very
very well I have not added that the heat
therapy after that but I'm going to
experiment with that at some point but
if you can add cold after the exercise
or even heat whether it's a shower sauna
or a pull you can increase more benefits
especially if you're someone like me
that tends to have more genetics leaning
towards inflammation and that's been my
problem even in sports is that I have to
be very careful of over training
training and I also have to put a little
bit more attention on recovery between
the exercise and of course I didn't know
this when I was in sports and so I just
work out a couple times a day seven days
a week big mistake because at the end of
the wrestling season I could barely walk
the other thing I want to mention about
this topic is you have muscle
contraction and you have muscle
relaxation okay and the Motions that
shorten the muscle are called
contractions or concentric motions
they're shortening the muscle when you
elongate the muscle that's called
eccentric motion for example if I'm
going to do a pull-up I bring my my chin
Over the Bar okay when I let myself down
I elongate the muscle that's called
eccentric motion or for example let's
say I do a push-up
and then I let myself down slowly that's
also called eccentric motion and
sometimes we forget about that because
maybe we do this push-up where we're
pushing hard and then letting ourselves
passively go down or do a pull-up we're
pulling hard and then very quickly
letting ourselves go down the other
direction if you focus on The Eccentric
motions you will get a lot more benefits
from that workout that can be related to
doing a bench press or any type of
exercise focus on the negative motion
elongation of that muscle and you'll
have stronger muscles better recovery
bigger muscles faster muscles and even
delayed soreness because you're adding
more Force to that muscle and it's also
a good way to progress for example a lot
of times people can't do more than a few
pull-ups right if you were to get some
type of step stool and stand on the step
stool and help your body lift up with
that pull-up and then focus on slowly
letting yourself down The Eccentric
muscles and you do that after a while
probably two or three weeks you're going
to find that you're going to be able to
do way more pull-ups because you've
worked on the reverse motion of that
next topic is about carbohydrates if you
do a workout and you do a little snack
before during or after the workout like
a lot of people do they want to get
those carbs in there maybe they do a
protein bar with sugar or they might do
an energy drink Gatorade with sugar
you're shutting them benefits of you
know ketosis fat burning as well as
autophagy which is the recycling of old
damaged proteins in your body the kind
of the anti-aging effect so here you are
spending all this energy doing this
workout and then this little bit of carb
pretty much just nullifies the benefits
especially if you are trying to lose
weight around the midsection it's very
beneficial to build up to the point
where you exercise in a fasting State
maybe eat the next hour or hour and a
half or two hours later that would
actually give you more improvements now
that being said
when we're dealing with hormones insulin
always comes up when people work out and
we're told that insulin will help it's
an anabolic hormone it helps build that
muscle the research is mixed on that
kind of on some studies it says it does
other studies it says it doesn't but I
do know that it does affect the muscle
and the ability for proteins or amino
acids to go in the muscle and it
preserves the muscle from losing a
protein so what do we want to do do we
want to increase insulin or not well
when someone's a diabetic or they
consume a lot of carbs they have insulin
resistance and when you have insulin
resistance you actually have a
deficiency of insulin this is why like
even diabetics have more muscle loss or
people with insulin resistance they have
a hard time building their muscle so
what they've been told is like oh you
just need to increase your carbs so you
can increase insulin and build up more
muscle I wouldn't recommend that what I
would recommend is when you do the
ketogenic diet which is a low carb diet
bring your carbs up to 50 grams and the
type of carbs that you could do to
fulfill that would be berries so like
three cups of berries per day would give
you 50 grams grams of carbs maybe if
you're younger you can go a little bit
higher than that maybe up to 75 and the
other thing to know about insulin is
that you can also increase insulin by
eating protein like even if you had 20
grams of protein in a meal you would
still raise insulin to some degree not
as strong as carbs but you'll increase
it so you'll have more insulin and you
don't have to worry about increasing or
adding sugar to it but protein does
increase insulin but it also increases
the opposing hormone called glucagon
which also helps fat burning and helps
with muscle building I also recommend
adding in an electrolyte powder or more
electrolytes because potassium magnesium
calcium chlorides these are really
important in the muscle contraction and
relaxation and the power of the nervous
system as well as the muscle you're
going to find if you have sufficient
electrolytes you'll have stronger
muscles and you'll be more hydrated as
well but don't forget about the
electrolyte sodium the other point I
want to bring up is when you eat that
meal after you work out maybe one to two
even three hours later what should that
meal be well the most important thing to
talk about is protein okay and there's a
lot to this topic but I'm just going to
give you the the summary of it the
absolute best protein for muscle growth
repair exercise is red meat okay you can
do that in hamburger or steak or
whatever you can do also lamb which is a
red meat or other types of red meat why
is red meat so important not only does
it have more concentrated amino acids
and bioavailable amino acids then
chicken especially then plant-based
proteins which are very insufficient but
red meat is kind of what you're trying
to build you're trying to build your own
red meat and so you're going to get a
really good Smorgasbord of all the
factors that come along with building
muscle repair of muscle and giving
energy to the muscle so we have
something called carnitine and carnitine
is kind of like a little shuttle bus
that takes fat and it pushes it into the
motor or the mitochondria the energy
Factory it allows you to burn more fat
that's carnitine and that's in red meat
in high amounts then we have creatine
what does that do that gives your
muscles the fuel for high intense burst
of exercise and it just so happens that
red meat is loaded with creatine then we
have another one called carnosine that's
in red meat and that it can act as an
antioxidant to buffer some of the lactic
acid the acidity that's generated when
you exercise so that can actually
increase your performance increase your
longevity allow you to work out longer
but that's not all red meat also has all
the co-factors and I'm talking about
like iron the B vitamins that are
necessary to allow these amino acids to
work
you see if you just consume like whey
protein powder you don't get the
cofactors you don't get the vitamins and
minerals that allow that protein to be
metabolized like you would if you had
red meat I mean just think about this
for a second inside your muscles okay
what generates the energy is the
mitochondria I don't know if you've ever
taken biochemistry before but even if
you have most people still are still
confused on what this kreb cycle is all
about
the Krebs cycle is like an assembly line
of little things that occur inside the
cells inside the mitochondria and your
body's taking this food and transforming
it into energy as ATP storage and it's
turning food into the building blocks so
you can build up body tissue and body
chemistry
so that's simply what the Krebs cycle is
but what a lot of people don't know is
when you go through the different points
or stages on this assembly line you need
certain nutrients for that to work if
you are low in these certain nutrients
you get a bottleneck it just stops
working and that's going to affect the
Krebs cycle and that's going to back up
your energy and your biochemistry of
some place which is occurring somewhere
in the body and there's actually a way
to test it which I'm going to do some
videos about but the point is you want
this entire assembly line to be
free-flowing without any micronutrients
missing and I'm talking about iron B1 B2
B3 B6 B5 about magnesium I'm talking
about manganese and another nutrient
called coenzyme Q10 right that's in the
mitochondria as well well guess what
when you have red meat you don't have to
worry about it it's all in there if you
have a high quality like grass-fed beef
or hamburger whatever all of those
cofactors everything I talked about is
in a package it's inside there you have
everything you need to build muscle and
repair the muscle so these people that
are cutting out red meat they're maybe
doing chicken breasts which has way too
many omega-6 fatty acids and it's
definitely of lesser quality and so is
like plant-based protein that's like
really low on the list where sometimes
people think those are clean proteins to
help you they're not there's other
things you can do too you can do eggs
and those are good but if you do eggs
make sure they're not raw because the
raw can deplete your Biotin and it's not
nearly as bioavailable as the cooked
eggs another Protein that's not bad is a
real good high quality cheese okay think
about it where does cheese come from it
comes from milk in nature when does an
animal need milk when they're growing
why because milk has a lot of growth
factors to help muscle building and so a
little bit of cheese can do wonders on
your muscles for growth and increasing
muscle size
just don't do the low quality cheeses if
you can find a European cheese that's
literally raw that would be the best and
another thing about cheese is it's
fermented so it has the the additional
benefits of the microbes and it's better
than whey protein because whey protein
is a different type of protein and it's
like purified so it's kind of a refined
protein product one last thing about red
meat don't get the lean I mean if it
comes lean because the animal is lean
that's fine but don't try to have some
type of animal protein that they've
taken away the fat because again that's
refining the process grass-fed beef
would be the best but just don't try to
get the the leanest version but again
it's hard to fatten these grass-fed
animals because they're not feeding them
grains well that's fine but people are
tend to obsessing with this low-fat or
lean this and lean that even if you have
chicken just at least make sure it has a
skin on it or if you have fish it'd be a
little bit better if you have the skin
on it another point I want to talk about
is the recovery in between the workouts
so let's say you exercise and you get
sore if you're sore you should not
exercise over that soreness let your
body recover and sometimes it might take
more than a day or two or three or even
four days and instead focus on your
sleep but I just want to make one little
point about the sleep if you are an
athlete and you work out hard okay one
Trace metal that usually shows up low
and athletes is copper and that can
lessen your ability to sleep especially
the REM sleep so if you're an athlete
and you're finding that you can't get
the seven or seven and a half or eight
hours add a little copper before a bed
to your diet not a lot just a little bit
and watch what happens it might just
enhance your sleep you don't have to do
it for a long period of time maybe for a
couple weeks but the point is that that
exercise is depleting your copper and
you need to know how to get more Copper
from the diet now I've given you a lot
of tips of what to do to optimize your
workouts before during and after a
workout but there's some really
interesting information relating to
this red meat and and what's in a red
meat that can help you recover from
exercise and I put that video up right
here check it out